biontech has announced that it plans to
set up a new factory in singapore to
expand production in southeast asia
the german biotech company is also
setting up a joint venture in china to
produce up to one billion doses for the
chinese market
biontech is now supplying more than 90
countries worldwide
and is expecting to ramp up its
production to up to 3 billion doses by
the end of the year
during a pandemic this is the stuff that
dreams are made of
komenati the mrna vaccine developed by
german startup biontech
was approved less than a year after the
pandemic began
it's now mainly manufactured at bayern
tech's new plant in marburg germany
the hopes of many are pinned on its 450
employees
work is carried out around the clock
when i'm not at work of course it's
fascinating and i like to talk about it
especially when working on something so
important
but at work we're all focused on the
here and now it's important that
everyone is focused on what they're
doing next
so that no mistakes can happen and we
produce the right quality
and the right quantity after all the
pandemic is raging right now in many
emerging countries like
india to help u.s president joe biden
has proposed relaxing patent protections
but the pharmaceutical lobby
is not willing to cooperate because of
scientific research that we now have
drugs and treatments and medicaments and
vaccines
but it's because of the patterns that
companies keep
investing money into uh looking for
new treatments better treatments better
vaccines uh better drugs
and and you would not have this kind of
investment if
if there wasn't a proper reward for
these companies
plus the industry argues that vaccine
manufacturers
are already ramping up production to the
maximum that's the case in marburg
employees there produced some 250
million doses
in the first half of the year later
production will be ramped up to a
billion doses or more
construction is ongoing at the plant as
it expands production capacity
it took less than six months from the
purchase of the building
to refit and start production and that
in germany which has a reputation
for being painfully bureaucratic
it has to be said that the cooperation
with the various authorities worked very
well
when you build something new you have
all kinds of different people on board
many people joined in and were very
proactive
in the end that helped everything go so
quickly
of course you still have to adhere to
all the regulations as
always
for many emerging countries however the
pledges are not enough
they want to produce the vaccine
themselves so that as many as possible
can get
protection from the coronavirus
so biontech is ramping up production and
the market seem to like that
for more let's cross over to chelsea
delaney in frankfurt
chelsea at least about an hour ago i saw
that
shares surged investors seem to be
pleased about biontech expansion plans
well indeed the frankfurt listed shares
of biotech are up about 10 percent today
the
nasdaq shares in the u.s are also higher
uh
i think for the big question for
biontech has been
uh will the pandemic boost for this
company last they they really were put
on the map by that pandemic and their uh
their vaccine they went from this
relatively unknown money-losing start-up
to
a globally recognized name but investors
want to know
if this is something they can count on
for the long term and now we're really
seeing biontech
put forward plans for the future to
build these
uh facilities and in other countries uh
they they really expect the demand for
code vaccines to last uh
for years but they also in today's
announcement said that they're
going to plan on producing some other uh
of their treatments as well they've been
developing a lot of cancer treatments
they
have other infectious treatment disease
treatments in the pipeline
so they really are laying out this plan
to to become
not just a german cove vaccine
manufacturer but a globalized drug maker
and investors are really liking that
today
all right quite a story there chelsea
delaney in frankfurt thank you so much